see page c page play play page play what
the hell is page playing this is an
orchestra comprised entirely of fleets
this works because flutes can cover the
entire range of an orchestra on their
own from the piccolo at the top all the
way to the double Concha bees flew down
at the bottom very cool and there's
Paige playing you know back from the
intro
I'm Paige long and I'm a professional
flutist wait flutist or flautist
I like flutist she's one of a handful of
people playing the three largest flutes
in the flute family the contrabass flute
the sub contrabass flute and the double
Concha bass flute let's learn about big
flutes in its case the double contrabass
flu weighs approximately 30 pounds it
stands over eight feet tall and it's 22
feet of too big the sub contrabass flute
in g has 11 feet of tubing and the
contrabass in c has 9 feet of tubing so
how does one play an instrument with 22
feet of tubing for these lower flutes
it's a whole different technique your
embouchure is looser new word embouchure
um sure
embouchure embouchure is the way you
shape your mouth to make a sound on the
flute your mouth is looser bigger takes
a lot more air and a lot more support I
feel like I've run a 10k when I'm done
with a concert because it's hard to get
a clean low sound they actually play the
lowest possible notes of an orchestral
instrument say Louis of any orchestral
instrument now what does that mean hey
guys can you help us out here
well alright ready boys the double
contrabass flucos low lower than any
instrument can go
then stream is a big old guy he may step
aside fly and what's next
it's the sub contrabass flute hit it
another big flute sounds like a bassoon
the sub contrabass can carry a tune the
contrabass flute is the smallest fellow
it sounds just like a cello wow thanks
now I understand so Paige what do you
like about these giant flutes in the
land of flutes they're like the
subculture of the flute community and we
provide a role that the concert flute
cannot it all checks out Paige play us
out
[Music]